well let's talk about censorship
manipulation I was uh talking with
congresswoman bobert and uh I gotta say
I'm a bit pessimistic because on this
show for instance we've had on only a
few guests who are more liberal leaning
and we invite many on but many just
don't want to do it the only ones who do
either are up and coming and looking for
an opportunity which you know we're
trying to
we do want to have some of these
individuals I don't want to limit
someone's ability to speak because
they're not famous or anything like that
but we're trying to engage in debates
with people who are influencing the
debate itself but they don't want to and
often what we find is people like Squad
members either are intentionally lying
or don't know what they're talking about
an example I'll give is when AOC today
said during the Twitter uh hearings that
Boston's Children Hospital was lied
about by Libs of tick tock claimed that
they were giving hysterectomies to
children but they actually list on their
website reportedly that they that they
offered hysterectomies to adolescents if
we want to be specific and there was
even a video where they described gender
affirming hysterectomies at a children's
hospital so either she knows what she's
saying is not true or she genuinely
believes incorrect things yeah if big
Tech is censoring conversations and even
us right now on this show are subject to
those restrictions how can we advance
the country in a positive direction come
to real solutions make people's lives
better if we can't even discuss the
problems no that that's the problem and
I think you've hit on the sort of the
key thing here the left today doesn't
embrace the First Amendment and that is
literally something that has changed in
my judgment in the last 10 to 15 years
it used to be the left with you know get
your best hold make your best argument
full Embrace of the First Amendment your
right to speak and let's let's let's
have the debate and see see who wins and
then we move on to the next issue that's
the way it used to be but not today
today the left says if you don't agree
with me you're not allowed to talk and
if you try we're going to call you
racist we're going to call you fascists
we're going to call you names we're
going to try to cancel you and I've said
this on the house floor when we were
talking about the whole cancel culture
uh culture phenomena I said don't think
that they won't come for you it's not
just they're coming after conservatives
or Republicans or libertarian they're
going to come for everybody and that
very week if I remember right that very
week is the week they said the Diane
Feinstein Elementary School in San
Francisco will no longer be named after
Senator Feinstein she wasn't good enough
liberal icon not good enough because of
something she said 30 40 years ago that
is the problem and and look I got
liberal friend Dennis kucinich is a
friend of mine and you know he's way
over here and he thinks Jordan's way
over here but we're friends and he
believes in the First Amendment that's
the problem today is if you don't if you
don't go along with the left they try to
cancel you and their appetite I think
knows no bounds knows no end and they
will come for everyone that's why we got
to push back and we got to push back on
big Tech so that we have that Public
Square that Forum that Forum that is now
the Public Square are you winning
I think we're making some progress
finally and of course the biggest win
was Elon Musk Buy on Twitter and showing
us what was going on as my my good
friend Thomas Massey said he bought a
crime scene cost him billions of dollars
but he bought a crime scene
um and uh laying out what happened there
that first they had their written
policies that they enforce selectively
and then the closer they got to the
election the more they enforce them
selectively and then when their policies
weren't good enough they just had an ad
hoc way of like we're going to do
whatever we want to do and censor
whoever we want to censor do you think
the Twitter Executives lied today in
these hearings I think they didn't tell
us everything because you know one of
the things I just one question I'm just
talking with Lauren when she asked about
the hearing today too and I said the one
question sort of stuck on me I asked
because I looked at you know Baker's
testimony Jim Baker who was deputy chief
counsel and before that he was Chief
counsel of the FBI and um on the top of
the second page of his thing he says
that he he did an improperly suppress
any information that would be good for
the public dialogue well if you didn't
improperly suppress then you believe you
properly suppressed something what was
it and when did it happen and he
wouldn't he wouldn't answer it and he he
had behind a privilege
um but I I want to know if that's right
around the time that the Twitter files
were when musk bought Twitter and
they're doing the Twitter files and they
find out those are being filtered
through Jim Baker was he suppressing
information then I don't know so that
was one of the takeaways I had I wonder
if there's potentially an FTC violation
with Twitter in that before Elon Musk
took over and even now there was this uh
before Elon Musk when you're on your
Twitter feed there's little stars in the
top right corner you click it it says
switch between your home feed which is
algorithmic and the latest tweets which
means that a user like me or any other
person who signs up if we select latest
tweets we expect to see the posts from
individuals we follow in Reverse
chronological order right but Twitter
was manipulating that feed while
advertising falsely what they were
delivering to people yeah so we ask
about that today so we asked um
great point we asked okay so when
someone gets their account suspended or
gets suspended from it or their tweets
being you know taken down they there's a
notice of that but if they're doing what
they call other visibility filtering
like blacklisting someone stopping them
from trending they don't know that and
it's happening and I ask them like is is
are you doing that on specific accounts
is it driven by certain key words that
that that that enforce that how is that
done and they didn't really seem that at
least I didn't figure out how they how
they were answering that but the fact
that they were doing that and people
didn't know then I said did that happen
to any government officials or elective
officials and he said he didn't know but
he thought it did so this is this is
Joel Roth uh who we asked this question
to so again that's something and the the
examples in the Twitter files are
bongino and uh and Charlie Kirk that
that that happened to them and they
didn't know probably happened to you and
you oh yeah you know about it there
there are these apps you can use where
you enter your name and it'll tell you
the various filters that exist but even
Dave Rubin just mentioned Elon Musk just
showed him new ones they discovered new
filters but but I guess you know what
I'm thinking is
we often focus on the censorship aspect
which I think culturally and morally
those of us who care about real debate
and and logic and policy are shocked by
but I'm also curious how can Twitter as
a massive Corp company with 300 million
plus users lie about the product they're
delivering how can a corporation in
America say I'm gonna imagine this
imagine if a company said you come to me
here's a contract you get a gallon of
whole milk then they give you a gallon
of two percent yeah that sounds like
they're they're they're falsely
advertising what they're delivering if
Twitter says the reverse chronological
feed delivers you reverse chronological
posts but then they're using Shadow ban
algorithms and we know they are they're
lying to their customers as the product
being delivered how is that legal how is
that allowed yeah so one of the
questions asked too that you made me
think of this too I asked this question
um and I I didn't fully understand but
but I asked if they were hard coding
into any specific accounts to censor
them so they're like targeting that
specific user uh and it was interesting
how Joel Roth kind of I want to go back
and look at the transcript to see
exactly how he said it because he really
didn't answer that square
um that either I agree one of the things
we want to do with with legislation that
we're we're planning on work doing with
Energy and Commerce Committee
is anything they do to your account they
have to tell you there has to be real
transparency there has to be a time
frame there has to be a due process so
that you can correct it figure out what
it is to have the debate and practice
within a specified amount of time and
then if they don't then you should have
some kind of cause of action because
they're violating a contract that they
have with you their user their customer
and the the scary thing about what we've
really learned I think from the Twitter
files too is all the things they're
doing Twitter but why in the world is
the FBI coming in and telling Twitter
hey these accounts have problems they
violate your terms up to what of service
Twitter like well what's the government
telling Twitter these accounts violate
Twitter's terms of service what you got
to be kidding me because it wasn't
because they were concerned about you
know you being Shadow band or anything
else it was because they wanted those
accounts taken down that to me is the
scariest part of all which is is come
out in the Twitter policy do you think
that those Revelations that uh Twitter
and Facebook had portals for government
agencies to flag content do you think
that was partisan that that the the yeah
Democrats I do because you know
the way I did it my my first round the
question Dave is I just I asked you know
was the hunter Biden's laptop story did
the government tell you it was fake no
did the government tell you it was
hacked no
um and then I said and did it violate
your terms of service and he said no it
didn't but you took it down anyway why'd
you take it down
I think they took it down because
for months they've been meeting with uh
excuse me they've been meeting with
Twitter they had uh asked Twitter if
they wanted security clearances in 30
days prior to the election they'd send
them all kinds of of emails heading on
the email said Twitter folks as if they
were best buddies and then they had the
secret what I call the super secret
James Bond teleporter app that they
could send messages to that would that
would you know go away and disappear
within a matter of weeks so they do all
this and they're telling them be on the
lookout for hack and leak operations I
think they they play Twitter and they
understood oh this is and and they were
a receptive audience you know like what
it must say 99 of them vote Democrat and
Democrats so that was the environment
they didn't need this specific email
that said take down the hunter Biden
laptop story
um they were all primed to do it based
on what the FBI had done for months and
months meeting after meeting a text
message or excuse me email after email
they were primed to do it and that's
what they did someone uh chatted just
now I think it's an important point they
said that we're not the uh we're not the
customers of big Tech with a product
it's a misunderstood standing and I
understand the point the the real
customer in a true sense of trans a
transactional customer is the
advertisers who are buying access to
data and access to an audience but I
think in a legal sense we the users of
Twitter are still customers yeah there
may not be a financial transaction but
there's a contract between us as to what
we get and in exchange for the the
policies in terms of services I mean
yeah it's a contract it's a contractual
agreement yeah so I guess you know the
challenges I suppose we're seeing now is
you know look you guys may have gotten
just a modicum of of Power by by taking
back a few extra seats in the in the
house giving you this majority but is it
enough to create a long-standing impact
to pass laws to actually get something
done are these hearings going to be
enough to actually change things well I
mean look we hope so and all we can do
is is what we can do and you know we got
our first hearing tomorrow in the select
committee uh we hope this is a community
or excuse me a hearing that begins to
frame it up
um we're having Chelsea gabbard as one
of our Witnesses I think she'll be great
she's a True Believer in the First
Amendment
um we have a couple great Senators
Senator Grassley Senator Johnson who've
been investigated and some of the things
they told us that the Democrats and
these folks did to them and FDI did to
them so we think it'll be a good hearing
and then of course we have on the second
panel we have um Professor Turley who's
who's op-ed out this week I think is
really good because he used the term
censorship by surrogate and that's what
we have now you got the pressure from
the government without explicitly
telling them to do certain things at
least we haven't found that yet but that
may we may find that but the pressure
from the government and then the
censorship from the tech platforms
um is real and when you view it in this
in my mind you viewed in this bigger
framework of what we've seen the last
couple years I always tell folks every
single right we enjoy under the first
amendment has been assaulted in the last
couple years everyone you're right to
practice your faith your right to
petition the government right to
assemble freedom of press freedom of
speech speech being the most important
all of them have been attacked by the
government many of them in relation to
covet and the coveted policies but a
host of other things too and it's it's
really frightening you know what was the
craziest thing about all that too is
even the third amendment got violated
did you see that one the third amendment
the one that no one knows because no one
talks about is that the government can't
put soldiers in your house right because
this is back in the revolutionary period
and then when they did living troops
yeah the eviction moratorium effectively
created the circumstance in which uh
active duty soldiers who are renting
property could not be evicted in
violation of the third amendment they
violated so much of the Constitution
they woke up the third it's it's it's
it's amazing and kind of scary at the
same time I still remember uh you know
they the government told you you
couldn't go to church crazy I mean the
government said you couldn't come to
your own Capital that you pay for I mean
we're here in Capitol Hill now but you
couldn't come to Europe for like a year
and a half Nancy Pelosi wouldn't let you
in your Capital that you pay for to
petition your member of Congress to
redress your Grievances and the one I
always remember is is Jin saki standing
at the White House in The Press Room now
think about the White House is
considered the the center of freedom on
the planet here's the press secretary to
the United States uh to the president
United States in The Press Room and she
stands at the podium she says most
Americans now get their information from
social media platforms we the by the
ministration are working with social
media platforms to limit the information
Americans can see it was alive and I'm
like
did I just see that press secretary in
the Press White House Press briefing
room saying she wants to limit the Press
I mean like this is this is scary where
where to go yeah they cheer it on this
is what I was uh I was saying to
congresswoman bobert a moment about
about an hour ago the way I view this is
with the manipulation of social media
the Restriction of information to the
American people the hunter Biden laptop
story right before an election being a
really prime example of this they've
created what I would describe as a
hypoxic portion of the United States
that is when when your brain is deprived
of oxygen you don't know you don't know
I don't know if you've ever seen these
videos but they're actually quite
revealing they'll put a person in in a a
seal chamber with a certain level of
oxygen and they'll slowly lower it while
asking them to answer basic math
questions to the person they're saying
one plus one is two two plus two is four
Bob if it is 17. but in their mind
they're saying everything correctly
really then they play back the video for
them and the people are like what I was
speaking gibberish yet your brain had no
oxygen so you were slowly shutting down
when they deprive half this country of
information and these people get their
news and information from CNN or MSNBC
who have both just espoused so much
garbage we we have a situation where I
would describe it as half one the the
left hemisphere of our American
Consciousness is deprived of oxygen
unaware that it's for the past seven or
eight years been manipulated and just
deprived of facts but it's still voting
so how do we vote to correct a problem
when we are we are facing people who
don't know they're facing a problem and
they're voting continually to increase
that problem if you know what I mean no
I I I get it we do the best we can you
pray for this great country you keep
with a smile on your face like you guys
do you you keep giving the facts and the
truth wrap up the belt harvesting yeah
and you and you play Under the rules
like the rules of the game are such that
that you play under those rules and you
do it the best you can uh and you play
to win I have a solution uh we could
free the software code of large social
networks right now instead of trying to
break up the companies force them once
they get to a certain number of users we
treat it as a Commons and the software
code is proliferated I think that's
where I think musk is thinking about
doing that I think that's where he may
be headed we could use government force
and say you know it's like it's breaking
up into Monopoly but I
I think that would work and then you
Federate the networks and like my
version of Twitter and your version of
Twitter can see each other but if I want
to ban you on my network I can I still
have my my right as a as a business
owner to ban whoever I want but that
that would require a very large cultural
shift and it's and it's and it's
difficult thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time